hola andrés qué tal si una mesa de
negociación que comenzó el pasado jueves
21 de julio y en la que el día de ayer
ya se había avanzado en el tema de la
canasta alimentaria se redujo en un 30%
con 72 artículos que fueron incluidos
allí para la tarde de hoy ya se había
avanzado también en el segundo punto que
tenía que ver con el precio del
combustible ya el gobierno del
presidente cortizo había establecido un
precio entre 25 dólares por galón
ese precio trató de ser bajado por parte
de los gremios que están sentados con el
gobierno a tres dólares sin embargo el
gobierno rechazó con la rechazo a esa
propuesta se mantiene entre 25 dólares
el galón sin embargo a ser ampliado a
todo el territorio nacional porque
precisamente los representantes de estos
gremios habían estado denunciando que a
pesar de que se había hecho efectivo
esta reducción la semana pasada en todo
el país estaba cobrando se ese precio el
siguiente punto que estaba previsto en
la agenda son en total 8 puntos
se están discutiendo en esta primera
fase en la mesa de negociación tiene que
ver con el tema de la reducción de
precios de los medicamentos y comenzaría
esta misma tarde el presidente de la
republica a laurentino cortizo viajó a
la ciudad de penonomé donde se está
llevando a cabo esta mesa de diálogo
para hablar con el representante de la
iglesia católica que está siendo
mediador en todo lo que tienen que ver
estas conversaciones para pedir que se
ha incluido el sector privado en esta
mesa de diálogo bueno eso en cuanto a
los acuerdos oscar y cómo están hoy las
vidas panameñas
las vías panameñas el día de hoy se
abrieron ya comenzó la circulación de
vehículos a lo largo de toda la
carretera panamericana una carretera de
más de 700 kilómetros que también
conecta con centroamérica y sobre todo
en la zona cercana a la zona fronteriza
con costa rica que había sido el foco de
cierres permanentes los indígenas las
comunidades indígenas que estaban en
esta zona decidieron
abrir las vías también hubo algo de
presión en la tarde de ayer por sectores
de productores que se habían visto
afectados precisamente por estos cierres
sin embargo a pesar de que se abrieron
las vías al día de hoy continuado en
manifestaciones entre docentes en varios
puntos del país incluyendo la capital
una marcha que se realizó en el ciudad
de panamá